PROFESSOR: Today we finish
up chapter 13.
I think we are finished, but
I'll take questions.
We get into chapter 14, which
starts to get into coding for
bandwidth-limited channels.
Here we're coding directly in
terms of Euclidean space
rather than in terms
of Hamming space.
And there's this wonderful
quote from Neil Sloane.
"Euclidean space coding is to
Hamming space coding as
classical music is to
rock'n'roll." Meaning that, in
the Euclidean space, things
are continuous, whereas we
were discrete back
in Hamming space.
Nonetheless, there are strong
connections between the two,
which in two lectures I'll
basically only have a chance
to hint at.
You were supposed to hand in
problem set nine last Friday,
or today if you haven't
already.
Today, we'll hand out the
solutions for nine, and then
chapter 14 and its problems,
which are problem set 10.
These are not due.
As always, I recommend
you do them.
The solutions will be handed
out Wednesday.
However, on the exam, the exam
will not cover chapter 14.
So everything we do this
week is gravy.
The exam is a week from tomorrow
in the morning.
Ashish will administer it
because I won't be here.
For this exam, it's closed book,
except you're allowed to
make five pages of notes,
as you did three
pages on the midterm.
And I do recommend you bring a
calculator, because for one of
the problems the calculator
will be helpful.
And I was told that erasable
memory should be cleared on
the calculator, so point of
honor if you do that.
Any questions about the
exam or chapter 13?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Are you including the
midterm [UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, oh, everything
in the course up to
chapter 13.
The rule is everything that
we covered in class.
If we didn't cover it in
class, then you're not
responsible for it.
Other questions?
Any last questions
on chapter 13?
This is kind of the finale
for binary codes.
We found that, at least on the
binary erasure channel, we had
techniques that would allow us
to design LDPC codes that
would get us as close to
capacity as we liked, or at
least I made that assertion,
directed you to where you
could find that done
in the literature.
And I further asserted that, at
least for binary symmetric
input channels, like the binary
additive white Gaussian
noise channels, you could do
much the same thing using
techniques like density
evolution or EXIT charts.
Again, the issue is to design
code, such as this iterative
decoding, after many, many, many
iterations, will, with
probability one, converge to the
correct solution (or with
probably one minus epsilon).
So that's the great conclusion
to the story for binary codes,
channels in which we want
to have binary inputs.
And way back in the beginning,
we said that that was
perfectly sufficient, really,
for the general additive white
Gaussian channel.
When we were talking about
binary code rates less than
1/2, or nominal spectral
efficiencies less than one bit
per second per Hertz, which
are equivalent statements.
So what happens if we want to go
over channels where we want
to send at higher spectral
efficiencies?
We want to send four bits per
second per Hertz, as we
certainly do over, say,
telephone line channels, which
are 3,000, or 4,000-Hertz
channels, over which we want
to send tens of thousands
of bits per second.
Or many radio channels will
support high numbers of bits
per second per Hertz,
and so forth.
Well, obviously, you can't do
that with binary codes.
So, today and Wednesday in this
chapter, we very quickly,
of course, go through the series
of techniques that have
been developed to go over
bandwidth-limited channels
such as the bandwidth-limited
additive white
Gaussian noise channel.
Clearly, you're going to need
a non-binary constellation,
and somehow code on that
constellation.
But what you'll see is that both
the techniques and much
of the development are
very reminiscent
of the binary case.
Historically, the binary case
was always done first, and
then the generalizations
to non-binary followed.
And so we'll see --
you can start off with very
simple, hand-designed
constellations, as we were
doing back in the early
chapters, four and five.
We played around with little m
equals eight constellations
and tried to optimize them from
the point of view of,
say, minimizing power for a
fixed minimum distance between
points in a certain number of
dimensions in Euclidean space.
Now, we want to go up to
considerably longer
constellations.
So that was kind of at the level
of Hamming codes and
single parity-check codes and
very elementary binary coding
techniques like that.
So we want more complicated
codes, let's say moderate
complexity codes.
We will find things that are
analogous to block codes,
linear block codes,
namely lattices.
These are structures in
Euclidean space that have the
group property, as linear
block codes do.
And then we'll find trellis
codes, which are the Euclidean
space analog of convolutional
codes.
And basically, our goal in the
next two lectures is to get to
the level of a union-bound
estimate analysis of the
performance of these kinds of
coding techniques, which, like
their binary analogs, sort of
sit in a moderate complexity,
pretty good performance, get up
to 6 dB coding gain, can't
get to capacity.
So that's as far as we'll be
able to go in chapter 14.
In the last page or two of
chapter 14, I briefly mention
higher performance techniques.
And it's generally accepted that
you can get as close to
capacity on these
bandwidth-limited channels,
additive white Gaussian noise
channels as you can on the
binary channels, in some cases
just by adapting binary
techniques in a kind of
force-fit way, and others that
are somewhat more principled,
I might say.
But in any case, by adapting the
binary techniques, you can
get turbo codes, low-density
parity-check codes, capacity
approaching codes of various
types for the
bandwidth-limited channel.
But I just hint how that can
be done in one page, and I
can't include it
in the course.
So that's where we're going.
So basically, we're trying to
design a constellation set of
signal points.
Constellation c or signal
set or alphabet,
script c, if you like.
And we're doing the kind of
things we were doing back in
chapter four and five.
What are some of the things that
the parameters we have--
we're going to do this in
n-dimensional space.
We're going to be concerned
with the size of the
constellation, the log of the
size, the number of log 2 of
the size, the number of
bits we can send.
We call this m at one point.
That will determine the number
of bits we can send per n
dimensions, or we can
normalize it per two
dimensions.
Typically, I said, in
bandwidth-limited regime,
we'll normalize everything
per two dimensions.
We're going to have an average
power of the constellation,
which I'm just going
to write like that.
We're going to have a minimum
squared distance between
points in the constellation,
which I'm going
to write like that.
And the idea is to optimize
the trade-off
between this and this.
Clearly, if I take a given
constellation and I scale it
up, I'm going to get better
minimum squared distance
without the cost of
increasing power.
So I either fix the minimum
squared distance between
points and try to minimize the
power, the average energy over
the centroids of a bunch of
spheres, or vice versa.
So when we do this, this is kind
of the game, we get into
a classical problem called
sphere-packing.
If we say, hold the minimum
squared distance constant,
that means we want to have a
certain minimum distance.
Here I'll make it
d_min over 2.
That means that there's going to
be a sphere of radius d_min
over 2 around each point in this
space, which must not be
violated by the sphere
of any other point.
So basically, we're trying to
pack spheres as closely
together as we can.
And we're maybe given
the dimension.
Here I have two dimensions
to play with.
We may be given the number, m.
In general now, we're going
to be thinking of m
becoming very large.
We want to go to arbitrarily
large number of bits per
second per Hertz.
So think of schemes that will
continue to work as we add
more and more points.
And if I do that in two
dimensions, we get
penny-packing.
Take a bunch of seven pennies
out of your pocket, and try to
squeeze them together as
tightly as you can.
That's effectively what
we're trying to do.
They maintain their fixed
radius, and you get something
that quickly starts to look like
what this is called, a
hexagonal sphere-packing,
because the centers line up on
a hexagonal grid.
And in fact, I forget
exactly what we did.
We did some of these back
in the early chapters.
And let me draw a 16-point
constellation, which I
remember we did draw.
Here's a constellation
consisting of 16 pennies.
And subject to my drawing
ability, it's packed as
closely as possible for a fixed
minimum distance between
the points.
And as far as anyone knows, this
constellation, consisting
a set of points on a hexagonal
grid, is the most dense
packing of 16 points in two
dimensions, as measured by the
average power of the centers.
And it's not very symmetrical,
but you can see it's based on
a symmetrical packing.
This hexagonal, this is
basically a subset of 16
points from the hexagonal
lattice.
If we extend these points
in all directions--
again, I haven't done
it very well--
but the hexagonal lattice
is simply the
underlying lattice here.
Let me just draw a set of points
that look like this.
I'm going to fail again.
Sorry, I'm better at rock'n'roll
than I am at
classical music.
Anyway, this is the lattice,
and it's called hexagonal
because, if we draw the decision
regions for this
lattice, if we consider this
as a set of points in a
constellation and draw the
decision regions, it looks
like that, this little hexagon,
defined by the six
nearest neighbors.
They define six sides
of a hexagon.
And so each lattice point has a
little region of space that
belongs to it, you can think
of as its decision region.
Now, what makes this
a lattice?
What's the definition
of a lattice?
We'll say an n-dimensional
lattice.
Very simple and elegant
definition for a lattice.
It's a discrete subset.
That means a set of discrete
points of Rn, sitting in
Euclidean n-space, that has
the group property.
And you now all remember
what that means.
It means the group property,
under ordinary addition of
vectors in Euclidean n-space,
addition or
subtraction, of course.
What are some of the
implications of
having a group property?
That means that the sum of any
two vectors is another vector
in the lattice.
Does the lattice have
to include the
0, the origin point?
Anybody?
Oh, good.
I'm going to ask this
on the final.
Come on.
Does it or doesn't it?
AUDIENCE: It does.
PROFESSOR: It does.
Why?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, that's
one good answer.
It has to be closed under
addition and subtraction.
Subtraction of the point from
itself is going to give you 0.
A more mathematically trained
person would probably, say,
well, it obviously has
to have an identity.
Every group has an
identity element.
And that means, if lambda is
in the lattice, does minus
lambda have to be
in the lattice?
Yeah, every element has
to have an additive
inverse, and so forth.
Well, so if I have a lattice
like this, that means that one
of these points has to be the
origin, say this one.
Now, of course, you can have a
translate of a lattice, and
geometrically it has all the
same properties as the lattice
itself, at any fixed t to
all the lattice points.
In other words, make the
origin somewhere else.
But that's not itself a group.
That's the co-set of a group.
It would translate as
a co-set operation.
So lambda must be a group, and
lambda plus t, any lambda
translate is a co-set
of lambda.
So most of the things you say
about lambda are also true for
lambda plus t, but in order to
fix a group, we need the
origin to be part of
the points set.
OK, if it's a group, what
does that mean?
That means, if we take any
particular point, say this
one, regard it as a vector,
then call this lambda_1 --
or let me it g1, more
suggestively.
Does g1 plus g1 have
to be in the group?
Yes.
So that forces this point
to be in there,
2g1, 3g1, so forth.
All of these have to be in
there, as well as minus g1,
minus 2g1, and so forth.
So basically, once we found a
generator, all integers times
that generator have to
be in the lattice.
So that means there's a
cross-section along the axis
defined by g1, such that these
points are simply the
integers, scaled by whatever
the norm of g1 is.
And of course, that holds for
any of these neighbors here.
You want to look for nearest
neighbors of 0's.
Take g2 and then, of course, all
of its integer multiples
have to be in the lattice.
So we've got a set here that, in
some sense, spans n-space.
We have now two vectors,
g1, g2, which are
not linearly dependent.
They're sitting in 2-space.
So if we take all real linear
combinations of these two
vectors, we're going to
get all of 2-space.
If we take all integer linear
combinations of these two
vectors, they all must be
in the lattice, right?
By the group property?
We've already proved that all
the integer multiples of
either of them is in the
lattice, so any thing plus or
minus those two.
So certainly, the lattice
includes the set of all
integer multiples of a_i times
gi, where i equals 1 to 2,
where a1, a2 is in the
two-dimensional integer,
lattice Z-squared.
Could there be any
other points?
There actually could, if you
made a mistake and picked your
initial vector to be 2g1,
because then you wouldn't have
taken account of g1.
So you've got to take your two
initial vectors to be two of
the minimum norm points
in the lattice.
But if you do that, then you can
easily prove that this is
all of the lattice points.
So in fact, a two-dimensional
lattice is equal to a set of
all integer linear combinations
of two
generators, which we can write
as a little two-by-two
generator matrix, G. Or very
briefly, we could write lambda
as G times Z-squared, and we
can view it as just some
linear transformation
of Z-squared.
So in this hexagonal lattice, we
can view it as starting out
with a square grid.
Of course, Z-squared itself
is a lattice.
Z-squared is a group.
This is just the square lattice
in two dimensions.
We have Z_n as a lattice in
n dimensions, in general.
So I take Z-squared, Z_n, more
generally, and I distort it.
I just run it through some
g, which is a linear
transformation, and slants some
of the generator points.
And that's a general way
of getting a lattice.
That's not the way we
usually visualize
the hexagonal lattice.
We usually visualize it in such
a way as to recognize
that it has six-fold symmetry.
But that's certainly
a way to get it.
And this has one interesting
consequence.
One of the measures we want for
a lattice is the volume
per lattice point.
In here, the volume, you can
divide this up into volumes
that are all of equal size,
and we call that
the volume of A2.
This lattice --
hexagonal lattice, is called
A2, and it's the volume of
that hexagon.
1 over the volume of that
hexagon is the density of
points in 2-space,
if you like.
So density is 1/volume.
I mean, think of every point as
having a unique volume, and
if we basically consider the
cells around each lattice
point, they fill up 2-space,
or the perfect tessellation
tiling of 2-space.
These hexagons will.
One easy consequence of the
group property is that all the
decision regions have to be
congruent, in fact, just
translates of one another
by lattice points.
The decision region around this
point is the same as the
decision region about 0,
translated by a lattice point,
namely the center of that
decision region.
I won't prove that but it's
true and easy to prove.
So that's one way of finding
what's the volume.
The volume will mean
the volume of
2-space per lattice point.
But what's another
way to do that?
Another way is just to take
this little parallelotope,
whose volume is easier
to calculate.
And we can see that we can
equally well tile 2-space with
these little parallelograms,
just anchor --
in this case, this is the one
that's anchored in the lower
left corner by the origin.
Then we take another one that's
anchored by this point.
We take another one that's
anchored by this point,
another one that's anchored
by this point.
And it's clear that's another
tiling of 2-space by regions,
one for each lattice point that
completely fills 2-space
with overlaps only on the
boundary, which don't count.
So the volume of A2 is also
the volume of that, what's
called a fundamental
parallelotope.
And what's the volume of that
fundamental parallelotope?
Well, one way of calculating
it is to take
the volume of Z-squared.
We can view this as the
distortion of Z-squared, which
looks like this.
So if this is Z-squared, what's
the fundamental volume
of Z-squared?
The volume of Z-squared
per lattice point.
This is (0,1,-1,1,
so forth,1,1).
What's the volume of
Z-squared per--
AUDIENCE: 1
PROFESSOR: --1.
Clearly.
And we have this decision
region.
This is little square side 1, or
this parallelotope is also
little square side 1.
It's volume is 1.
General geometric principle, if
we take this and distort it
by G, then what's the volume
of, say, this parallelotope
going to be?
This parallelotope goes by G
into this one, and its volume
is the Jacobian, which is
the determinant of G.
So the volume of a lattice
is the determinant of any
generator matrix for
that lattice.
Just a nice little side fact,
but it's an example of the
kind of things you get in
Euclidean space that you don't
get in Hamming space.
Of course, there are various
generator matrices that you
could use to generate
this lattice.
But whichever one you choose,
this is going to be true.
So this is an invariant among
all the generating matrices.
So that's a lattice.
I haven't mentioned what's the
most important thing for us
about a lattice.
A lattice is a group.
What's the fundamental property
of a group, which I
guess was embodied in
the alternate set of
axioms for the group?
If I take the group plus
any element of the
group, what do I get?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: The group again.
Let's interpret that
geometrically.
One of the nice things about
this subject is you're
constantly going back and forth
between algebra and geometry.
Geometrically, what
does that mean?
That means, if we take this
lattice, say the origin is
here, and we shift it, say, so
that the origin is up here,
then nothing changes.
Everything is invariant
to this shift.
We can do this for any
lattice point.
That shows you that
all the decision
regions have to be congruent.
It shows you that the number
of nearest neighbors, the
minimum distance from any point
to its nearest neighbors
is always the same for
any lattice point.
Basically --
it's a lattice is geometrically
uniform.
That means you can stand on
any of the points and the
world around you looks the same,
as if you stood on any
of the other points.
Think of these as stars in the
universe, and somebody
blindfolds you and drops you
on one of these points.
Can you tell which one of
those points you've been
dropped on if nobody's written
anything on these points?
No, you can't tell.
The world looks the same from
whichever one you drop on.
So that means the minimum square
distance from any point
is the same as every other.
So the number of nearest
neighbors at minimum square
distance is the same.
It means the total distance
profile, starting from any
point, is the same.
It means if we were to take one
of these points and send
it over a Gaussian channel from
a very large set, and we
take one of the points from the
interior and send it over
an additive white Gaussian noise
channel, the probability
of error is going to be the
same, regardless of which
point we send it from, because
the probability of error is
the probability of falling
outside your decision region.
And since the decision region
always has the same shape,
it's invariant to which
point you send.
So this geometrical uniformity
property, which that's the
general name for it and it
has all these specific
consequences that I just listed,
is the principal
geometrical property
of a lattice.
This just follows from
its group property.
You don't have to be a lattice
to have this property.
For instance, the translate of
a lattice is not a group,
technically, but it obviously
has the same geometrical
uniformity property.
And there are more elaborate
examples of things that look
less like lattices that
are nonetheless
geometrically uniform.
On the other hand, lattices
definitely are
geometrically uniform.
So this seems to be a good thing
to do, because what's
our objective?
We're trying to have
d_min-squared be the same for
every point in our
constellation.
We want to tack these pennies
as close together as we can.
That means we want to hold
d_min-squared constant for
every point that we're
going to use.
And so lattices have
that property.
So that seems like a good way
to do sphere-packing.
And in fact, sphere-packing, in
n-dimensions, is a very old
mathematical subject.
How many spheres can you
pack around a three
sphere, is it 12 or 13?
That was debated in the 18th
and 19th centuries, and I
think it's only finally just
been resolved a few years ago.
This turns out to be not
an easy problem.
The densest sphere-packing in
four dimensions was found in
the mid-19th century.
In eight dimensions,
I think around the
turn of the 20th century.
In 16 dimensions, it's the
Barnes-Wall lattice, which
we'll see a little later, which
was found in '54, about
the same time as Reed-Muller
codes, or maybe it was '59,
maybe a little later than
Reed-Muller codes.
The Leech lattice was certainly
found a little
earlier than that, but around
the same time as the Golay
code, to which it's a
very close cousin.
And so forth.
So you might think that these
questions had all been
settled, but in fact they're
still open for most specific
dimensions, n.
Conway and Sloane have the
authoritative book on this,
which basically lists what
we know about the densest
sphere-packings in
all dimensions.
So here's our idea.
Our idea is we're going to go
consult the mathematicians and
find out what the densest
sphere-packings that they
found are in various
dimensions.
In two dimensions, it's
the hexagonal lattice.
In one dimension, it's the
integer, and basically the
integers are the only packing
with regularity properties in
one dimension.
And two dimensions, you could
consider Z-squared, or you can
consider A2.
These are the two obvious
candidates, the square and the
hexagonal packings.
In three dimensions, you get
face-centered cubic packing.
And what's the BCC?
The base-centered cubic
packing, I guess.
AUDIENCE: Body-centered.
PROFESSOR: Say again.
AUDIENCE: Body center.
PROFESSOR: Body-centered,
thank you.
I'm sure you're right.
So anyway, there's some things
that are known about this from
classical mathematics and
current mathematics.
So our idea is we're going to
try to find the densest
possible lattice in
n dimensions.
But for digital communications,
for coding, we
only want a finite number
of points from that
constellation.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to create our
constellation based
on a lattice and
on a region of n-space.
And the idea is simple.
We're just going to intersect
the lattice.
Or maybe let me allow a
translate of a lattice with
the region.
And make this a finite,
compact region.
And this will give us a certain
finite subset of the
points in the lattice.
Now, when I draw a constellation
like this one,
of a size 16, that's
what I've done.
I've basically taken A2.
Or it's actually a
translate of A2.
I think the origin is
in here somewhere.
And I draw a sphere
around the origin.
And I take the 16 points
that happen to
fall within that sphere.
And I call that my
constellation.
So that's the idea in general.
Think of the region, r,
as a cookie cutter.
We're going to take the cookie
cutter and chop out a finite
number of points from this nice,
regular, infinite grid.
And that will give us
a constellation.
So especially for large
constellations, we'll be able
to make some approximations that
will allow us to analyze
that kind of constellation
very easily.
And actually, the best
constellations that we know
are of this type.
We've taken this baseline,
m-PAM.
Well, what's m-PAM?
We take the lattice plus t,
let's say to be Z plus 1/2.
So that means we don't take the
origin, but we take the
points 1/2 minus 1/2, 3/2.
They're equally spaced points,
but we've shifted them so as
to be symmetric about
the origin.
5/2 minus minus, so forth.
So this is Z plus 1/2
is our lattice.
And then if we want 4-PAM,
we take a cookie cutter
consisting of this region.
So this is the region going
from minus 2 to 2.
It's not unreasonable to expect
that, if we take a
region of length 4, we're going
to get 4 points, if,
again, it's symmetric around
the corner, because each of
these points takes up about one
unit of space over here.
So if we made it from minus 4 to
plus 4, we'd have a region
of length 8, and we'd
get 8 points.
And so forth.
So that's how we do m-PAM, and
then scale it if we want to.
But this is the basic idea.
Similarly, for m by m QAM, like
everything else, it's
just doing the same thing
independently in two
dimensions.
Here we take our lattice to be
Z plus 1/2 squared, which is
just the offset Z-squared,
offset so as to be four-way,
to be roughly symmetrical
to four-way
rotations, 90-degree rotations.
So here is Z-squared
plus (1/2, 1/2).
And then, again, here to get
16-QAM, for instance, we might
take the region to be what?
(-2,2)-squared which,
again, has area 16.
You might think of this as just
taking the little square
around each of these.
Each of these squares
has area 1.
So when we take the
union of all those
squares, we get the region.
That's another way of
characterizing this region.
It's just the union of all the
decision regions of the points
that we want.
If you had started from the
points, you could certainly
invent a region that
is the union of
those decision regions.
It would have an area equal to
the number of points times the
volume of 2-space
per each point.
That's the kind of
approximation
we're going to use.
The bounding region is clearly
going to have something like
the number of points in the
constellation, times the
fundamental volume
as its volume.
So this is our idea.
This is what we're going to call
a lattice constellation.
And we're going to investigate
the properties of lattice
constellations, not the most
general thing we could think
of but good enough.
Seem to have the right
sort of property.
And we're going to take it
at least as far as the
union-bound estimate, so we
can get a good estimate of
probability of error if
we take one of these
constellations, like m-by-m QAM,
and use it to transmit
over a Gaussian noise channel.
And furthermore, for large
constellations, meaning as we
get well up into the
bandwidth-limited regions of
large nominal spectral
densities, we're going to be
able to separate the analysis
into lattice properties and
region properties.
And we'll basically be able to
just add these up to get the
overall analysis, by making some
judicious approximations
that become exact in the large
constellation limit.
So let's now restrict ourselves
to lattices, or
translates of lattices, and
start to analyze them.
What are their key parameters
for our application, which is
digital communications?
Well, one is the minimum squared
distance between
lattice points.
We've seen that doesn't depend
on the particular point.
So this is the minimum
squared distance
from any lattice point.
The number of nearest
neighbors.
The volume per lattice point.
And is there anything else?
It seems to me there's
a fourth one.
No.
I guess that's all
we need to know.
So I want to combine these
into a key figure
of merit for coding.
Again, we did this back in
chapter four for a complete
constellation.
We found the figure of merit by
holding the average power
fixed for a fixed number of
points, m, on a fixed
dimension, n, and maximizing the
minimum square distance,
or, conversely, holding the
minimum squared distance fixed
and minimizing the
average power.
So we get some figure of merit
that was kind of normalized,
and we could just optimize
that one thing.
The key figure of merit was
called by 19th-century
mathematician, Hermite's
parameter, but we are going to
call it the nominal coding gain
because that's what it's
going to turn out to be.
And it's just defined
as follows.
The nominal coding gain of a
lattice is just this minimum
squared distance, so
it goes up as the
minimum squared distance.
But then we want to
normalize this.
And the obvious thing to
normalize it by, we want
something that's going
to scale as a
two-dimensional quantity.
If the lattice was scaled by
alpha, then this would go up
as alpha squared.
So we want something that'll
scale in the same way.
And what we choose to normalize
it by is the volume
of lambda per two dimensions,
if you like.
So you can see immediately, this
is invariant to scaling,
that the nominal coding gain of
lambda is the same as the
nominal coding gain
of alpha lambda.
Is alpha lambda a lattice,
by the way?
If lambda's a group, and we have
any scale factor alpha
greater than 0, then alpha times
lambda is also a group.
Everything's just multiplied
by alpha.
So alpha lambda is a lattice.
And this is actually one of
the homework problems.
If you scale everything by
alpha, d_min-squared goes up
by alpha squared.
The volume goes up by alpha
to the n, for an
n-dimensional lattice.
But when we take 2 over n, we're
going to get back to
alpha squared.
So alpha c of lambda is alpha
c of alpha lambda.
So this is what you want.
You want a kind of scale-free
version of a lattice, because,
obviously, when we use this,
we're going to feel free to
amplify it or compress
it any way we want,
so we do with QAM.
All right, so this is normalized
in that way.
We prove in the homework
it's also
invariant to other things.
If you took, say, an orthogonal
transformation of
this lattice, a rotation,
reflection, multiply it by a
matrix that doesn't change
the scale, think of it
geometrically as an orthogonal
transformation, is that going
to be a lattice?
It is going to be a lattice.
Everything's just going to have
some h out here, times G
times Z-squared, and
that's still of
the form of a lattice.
Or call it U for orthogonal,
unitary.
So we multiply it by some
orthogonal matrix, U. It's
still a lattice.
If we look in here, orthogonal
transformations don't change
squared distances.
We're not going to change this
-- it doesn't matter.
Actually, I might.
No.
It's a rigid rotation,
I'm sorry.
Everything here stays
the same.
Hexagonal lattice still is
hexagonal lattice, because
it's a rigid rotation or
reflection geometrically.
And the volume clearly stays
the same, so none of these
things changes.
And orthogonal transformation
isn't going to change this
quantity either.
So we can rotate this
or do whatever.
And then, finally, there's an
even more interesting one,
which is, if we take the
lattice, lambda to the m, this
is simply the Cartesian
product.
It's the set of all lambda_1,
lambda_2, lambda_m, such that
each of these lambda_k
is in Lambda.
So it's the set of all n-tuples
of elements of Lambda.
This clearly lives in dimension
mn, so it's a much
higher-dimensional lattice.
The simplest case is Z to the m
- it lives in m dimensions,
whereas Z is down in
one dimension.
So it lives in dimension mn.
It's a way of constructing
high-dimensional lattices from
low-dimensional lattices.
It's something that, in
communications, we consider to
be almost a non-event.
Sending a sequence of elements
of lambda is the same as
sending a sequence of elements
of lambda_m.
In fact, if we just send a
sequence of things from here,
and a sequence of things from
lambda, there's no difference
from a receiver's
point of view.
So we regard these two lattices
as equivalent, from a
communications point of view.
Well, what happens
to d_min-squared?
d_min-squared doesn't change,
because we can always--
d_min-squared is, by the way,
the weight of the smallest--
should have said that.
You can always do things
relative to 0.
d_min-squared, therefore, is
the squared norm or lowest
squared energy of any non-zero
lattice point, same as we did
with Hamming codes, just
by the group property.
K_min is the number
of such lowest
Euclidean weight points.
OK, here, what's the lowest
weight point?
It would look something like
this, where this is one of the
lowest weight points
in lambda.
So d_min-squared
doesn't change.
This changes, but we're
not considering that.
The volume, what
is the volume?
It turns out that it's not hard
to show that V(lambda to
the m) is V(lambda) to the m.
And therefore, you can show that
this is figure of merit
doesn't change, even if you
take Cartesian products.
So for instance, I chose that
the nominal coding gain of to
the m is equal to the nominal
coding gain of Z. Which is
what, by the way?
I should have done this
as the first example.
What's the minimum squared
distance of Z?
1.
What's the volume of Z?
So this is 1, or 0 dB.
We're going to measure nominal
coding gain in dB, which,
well, we're getting us
into communications.
What's the nominal coding gain
of the hexagonal lattice?
By asking this question, I'm
basically asking, is the
hexagonal lattice denser than
Z-squared in two dimensions
than the square lattice
in two dimensions?
And if so, quantitatively,
how much denser is it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, well, there's a
root 3 in it, but that isn't
exactly the answer,
I don't think.
There are various ways that you
can do it, but one of the
ways is to take, as a generator
matrix, (1, 0; 1/2,
root 3 over 2).
You like that as a generator
matrix for the--
That's taking this and this
as the two generators, and
recognizing this as 1/2, and
this as root 3 over 2.
That makes the length of this
equal to 1/4 plus 3/4, equals
1 square root, and it's 1.
So these are my two generators
of length 1 in a hexagonal
lattice of minimum squared
distance 1.
So based on that, I can say that
the volume of A2 is what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Root 3 over 2.
Not hard to take the determinant
of that, right?
And what's the minimum squared
distance in this scaling?
What's the minimum non-zero
weight --
squared norm, it's 1.
So this is equal to 1 over root
3 over 2, which is equal
to 2 over root 3.
Which is equal to what?
This is 3 dB.
This is 4.8 dB, roughly.
Square root is 2.4 dB.
So this is about 0.6 dB.
That's where it pays to
be facile with dB's.
This area, by the way, if you
tried to compute the area of
this little hexagon here,
what would it be?
If the area of this
parallelotope is the square
root of 3/2, what's the
area of this hexagon?
The same, right?
They're both space filling when
centered on lattice points.
So they have to have
the same area.
So that's an easy way of
computing the area of a
hexagon, or of this particular
hexagon anyway.
But you would get the same
result in either way.
So comparing this with
Z-squared, I now have a
quantitative measure
of how much
denser A2 is than Z-squared.
Put in one way, if I fix the
minimum squared distance of
each of them to be 1, if I'm
doing penny-packing and I say
I want pennies of a certain
radius to be packed into
two-dimensional space, then
this is 1 over the volume,
which is basically
the density.
The density of A2 is 2 over root
3, times [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
as the density of points
in z squared.
I get more points per unit area
with the same distance
between them using A2 than
I can with Z-squared.
So that's the significance
of this parameter.
So it's an obvious thing for
Hermite to have come up with.
It's going to turn out to be
equally fundamental for us.
So that may be all we want
to do on lattices
for the time being.
Yeah, seems to be.
So we're talking about lattice
constellations.
The other thing we have
to develop is the
properties of regions.
So let me talk about
regions, R --
I'm thinking of a compact
region in an
n-dimensional space.
So again, let me fix
the dimension to n.
And we're going to have
a certain volume.
That's obviously an important
characteristic of a region.
And I'm going to assume
that this is finite.
And what's the other thing
that we basically want?
Well, when I pick a
constellation like this, by
intersecting a lattice with a
region, eventually I'm going
to let the points in this
constellation be equiprobable,
as I always do in digital
communications.
16 points.
Say they all have probably 1/16,
the uniform probability
over the discrete points.
One of the approximations I am
going to make -- so what's the
average power of that
constellation?
We could figure it out by taking
1/16 times the energy.
I should say the average
energy, I'm sorry.
We're not talking power here.
We're talking energy, but I
read it as P. What's the
average energy?
It's 1/16 times the L2
norm of each of these
points, if you like that.
It's simply the Euclidean
squared norm.
And we get some average.
But here's the key approximation
principle.
I'm going to say the average
power of this constellation,
especially as the constellations
get large, is
simply going to be approximated
as the average
energy of a uniform distribution
over this
bounding region.
Suppose I simply put a uniform
continuous distribution over
this circle, this sphere, two
sphere that I've used to be my
cookie cutter.
I'm going to say that's going to
be a good approximation to
the average energy of the 16
discrete points, which are, by
construction, they're spread
uniformly over this region.
The approximation is, I'm kind
of approximating a unit
impulse of weight there
by distributed
weight across its--
well, actually across its
whole little region.
If we have a hexagon around each
one, uniform distribution
over the hexagon.
And if that's a reasonable
approximation, then it's
reasonable to say that the
average power of the whole
constellation is just the
average power of a uniform
distribution over this region.
It's good exercise to try it for
some moderate size cases.
And you'll find it is a very
good approximation.
In any case, it's the one
we're going to use.
So the other key parameter is
going to be P(R), which is, in
words, the average energy of
uniform distribution over R.
Sorry, script R. Now, when we
write this out, this actually
gets a little formidable.
So I think it's better to
remember what we're actually
trying to compute.
Oh, and one last thing,
we're going to
normalize it per dimension.
So what do I mean?
What's a uniform distribution
over R?
This is P(x equals 1) over
the volume of R for
x in R and 0 otherwise.
Uniform within, 0 outside.
And what does it
have to equal?
It has to be equal to 1 over
V(R), because its integral has
to be equal to 1 if it's a
probability distribution.
So to compute P(R), we basically
take the integral
from over R, of this probability
distribution, 1
over V(R), times what?
The energy per dimension.
The total energy of x is
x-squared, the L2 norm of x.
Normalize per dimension --
we're going to put an
n over there --
dx.
So that's an equation for what
it is I wanted to compute.
I think it's much harder to
remember the terms in this
than to remember this verbal
description of what we want.
But you may be more literate
than I. Now, let's define --
we want to normalize quantity
comparable to Hermite or
coding gain over here.
The normalized quantity
we're going to use --
we want to take P(R) -- and what
should we normalize it by
to make it scale-invariant,
let's say again?
Again, if I take the region, I
scale the region by alpha and
get alpha_R.
What's going to happen to the
average energy of a uniform
distribution over R?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It's going to
go up as alpha squared.
Energy scarce, goes as the
square of the scale factor.
So again, I want to normalize
it by V(R) over 2 to the n,
because this is also something
that will go up as alpha
squared if I scale R by alpha.
So this is what's known as the
dimension-less or normalized--
it has both names--
second moment.
Another name for this is the
second moment per dimension of
a uniform distribution over
R. This is a normalized or
dimension-less second moment.
I think I call it normalized in
the notes, but it's always
called G in the literature.
And let me just introduce
here--
well, what's the normalized
second moment of an interval?
Say, a symmetric interval
around the origin.
G to the minus 1 to the 1, which
is like the interval
that we used to pull out the
m-PAM signal structure.
So let's take n to be equal to
1, R just to be the interval
from -1 to +1.
And V(R) equals what?
It's the length of
R, which is 2.
What's P(R)?
The integral from -1 to 1, x
squared, dx, which is 2/3.
I think so.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right, 1/2.
Thank you.
That's 1/3.
All right, so what is G(R) going
to be, or G going to be?
This is going to be P(R)
over V(R)-squared.
And so this is going to be
1/3 over 4, or 1/12.
OK, that's not as nice as
this over here, but
it is what it is.
There's a number that shows up
in quantization, for instance,
uniform scalar quantizer, you'll
find a 1/12 in there.
Why?
It's because of this equation.
If we ask again about the
invariances of this--
this is the last homework
problem for this week--
it's invariant not only to
scaling, but, again, it's
invariant to orthogonal
transformations, because
orthogonal transformations
won't affect
either of these things.
A rigid rotation, about
the origin, won't
affect V(R) or P(R).
And furthermore, it's invariant
to Cartesian
products, again.
If we just have a series of
regions, a region made up
basically as the Cartesian
product, like an n-cube is a
Cartesian product.
We just pick each of the
dimensions independently from
some set R. Then that's not
going to affect the normalized
second moment either.
Exercise for the student.
So from that result, I can say
that G([-1 1]) to the m.
Which is what?
This is an m-cube of side 2.
If I say each of the
coordinates, x1, x2, x3, up to
xm, has got to be xk n times
[-1 1], then what I'm going to
get, the region defined by that
is an m-cubed, centered
on the origin of side 2.
So the normalized second
moment of that
is going to be 1/12.
This is where the shortcut
begins to help you.
I guess I'm trying to put
too much on one board.
But the last thing I want
to put up on here
is the shaping gain.
The shape gain of a region is
defined as the shaping gain of
the region is equal to 1/12.
So we're kind of taking as a
baseline, the m-cube, in any
number of dimensions n,
over G(the region).
In other words, how much less
is the dimension-less second
moment, the normalized second
moment, than what you would
get for an m-cube?
In every dimension except for
one, a sphere is going to be a
better region, from a second
moment point of
view, than an m-cube.
An m-cube has corners.
Really, it's pretty obvious
that, if you want to minimize
the normalized second moment in
any number of dimensions,
you would choose an m-sphere,
because if you have any
wrinkle that comes out of an
m-sphere, anything that's not
an m-sphere, you should try
to squash it back in it.
And that'll make
it an m-sphere.
You'll take higher energy and
make it lower energy for the
same little unit of Play-Doh
or mass stuff.
So a sphere will give you the
best normalized second moment
in any number of dimensions n,
so you're always going to get
a G(R) that's less than 1/12.
That's good.
And this measures the
amount of gain.
Again, you can measure
this in dB.
That's going to translate
directly to dB.
I suppose I could do an example
for the sphere in two
dimensions, but I won't.
How are we doing on time?
Let me see if I can do the
union-bound estimate.
That would be a trick, but I
think it's doable, because
this is where we're going.
So the union-bound estimate,
which is something we did way
back in chapter five or
something, is basically, given
a constellation, which we're
going to have a lattice
constellation based
on some lattice
lambda and some region.
So this is like our m-by-m QAM,
or it might be this guy,
which is better than 16-QAM,
in some sense.
In two senses, actually.
The union-bound estimate,
what is it?
The probability of error is
approximately equal to--
let me do it per block.
So I'll have the number of
nearest neighbors per block of
our constellation times Q
to the square root of
d_min-squared of our
constellation,
over what is it?
4 sigma squared?
4 sigma squared.
And if you remember how we got
this, we took the union-bound,
we took all the pairwise error
probabilities, and from that,
we get contributions from kd at
every kd contributions at
distance d.
We added them all up
in the union-bound.
We said, well, for moderate
complexity and performance, at
least this is going
to be dominated
by the minimum distance.
So this is the minimum
distance terms.
This is the number of minimum
And this is error
probability --
the pairwise error probability
we get for each minimum
distance term.
Now, to compute this, I'm
going to use three
approximations, but two
important ones, this
continuous approximation that
I've already referred to.
First, I'm going to say that
the average power of my
constellation is approximately
equal to just the second
moment of R. The average energy
per dimension of R.
And then I'm going to say,
furthermore, how many points
are there in the
constellation?
This will affect what
rate I can go at.
The average number of points
in the constellation --
also mention this--
is going to be approximately
equal to simply the volume of
my bounding region, V(R), over
the volume taken up by each
point in my lattice.
That makes sense, doesn't it?
What I want to do here to get
16 points is I take a sphere
whose area is roughly 16 times
the area of one of these
little hexagons or one of these
little parallelograms.
And I'll get about 16 points,
because that's
the density of it.
And there's a final little
approximation, which is that
I'm going to assume that we're
somewhere in the interior of
the lattice, so that the average
number of nearest
neighbors in the constellation
is simply equal to the number
of nearest neighbors
in the lattice.
So that's a reasonable
approximation, and that's a
very obvious one.
If I take any constellation
based on the hexagonal
lattice, for a large enough
constellation, the average
number of nearest neighbors
is going to be 6.
If I take it on the square
lattice, the average number of
nearest neighbors is
going to be 4.
But we know we're not terribly
interested in that either.
Let me do a little manipulation
here.
I'm going to write this as Q of
d_min-squared of c, which
clearly I'm going to also assume
that d_min-squared of c
is equal to d_min-squared
of the lattice.
So I'll make that d_min-squared
And I want to normalize that
by v of lambda, to the 2/n,
whatever dimension n I'm in,
to get something that we're
familiar with.
So I need a V(n) over
2 to the n.
And anticipating a little,
I'm going to put a V(R)
over 2 to the n.
And then over here, I'm going
to put V(R) over--
Is this going to come
out right?--
over 2 to the n, over--
this seems upside-down.
Ah, no, it isn't upside-down.
Because I'm using this
expression here, I
do want 1 over G(R).
So this is 1 over G(R).
If I multiply this by 1/12, now
I get 1 over G(R), so I
need to put a 1/12 here.
And then I have a P(R)
over 4 sigma squared.
So does everyone agree I
can write it that way?
This'll be good.
Go out with a bang.
So what are all these things?
This is the coding
gain of lambda.
This, according to this, is the
size of the constellation
to the 2 over n,
approximately.
The rate of the constellation
is log 2 times the size of
lambda, R. So the rate
is equal to just
log 2 of this quantity.
So I can say 2 to the R. This
is 2 to the R equals this.
So this would be 2 to the
2 over n, 2R over n.
Is that right?
Again, I'm unsure if
that's what I want.
This is the shaping gain of the
region, these three things
together, times 3,
times-- what's
P(R) over sigma squared?
That's the SNR.
That's the average power
per dimension.
And this is the average noise
power per dimension.
I've used up these in that.
So I've got a 1 over 1/12.
That's 12 times that.
So this is 3 times SNR.
And let's see.
This is 2R over n is
just 2 to the--
AUDIENCE: Isn't that just 2R?
Because [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
normalized by the dimension.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
And furthermore, it's minus,
because it's upside-down.
So it's 2 to the - 2R.
Actually, what I want is the
spectral efficiency.
And the spectral efficiency is
the rate per two dimensions.
So this is just 2 to
the minus rho.
So with a little help for
my friends, what's SNR
over 2 to the rho?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It's approximately
SNR norm.
Certainly true as row
becomes large.
It's actually SNR over
2 to the rho minus 1.
So this is SNR norm.
OK, so with a little hand waving
and a few high SNR
approximations, we get that, in
summary, for the UBE, the
probability of error is
approximately K_min(lambda)
times Q to the square root
of the coding gain of the
lattice, times the shaping
gain of the
region, times 3SNR norm.
And that's a wonderful
approximation.
Let me just call out some of
its properties to you, and
then we'll talk about
them next time.
But first of all, there's
nothing here--
all these terms involve either
lambda or R. So we have
completely separated, in this
analysis, the effects of the
region from the effects
of the lattice.
We can choose the lattice and
the region independently.
And they independently affect
how good a performance we get.
For the baseline, which was
either m-PAM or m-by-m QAM, we
have, for the baseline PAM or
QAM, we've set it up so that
both the coding gain of the
lattice and the shaping gain
of the region are equal to 1.
So for the baseline, this
gives us what we already
developed back in the
early stages.
I won't worry about this --
Q-hat, but it does give you
the right coefficient out
here, too, depending on whether
you normalize it per
two dimensions or what.
It just gives you Q to the
square root of 3SNR norm,
which I hope you remember
from chapter five.
So this is our baseline curve
for m-PAM or m-by-m QAM.
We just plotted versus SNR norm,
the probability of error
per two dimensions, which
is what I recommended.
And we got some curve.
So this is the baseline.
And now we've got everything
separated out in a nice way,
so that if somebody gives us a
lattice with a certain coding
gain and a region with a certain
shaping gain, those
both just add up as gains.
If that's all we had, forget the
coefficient, we would just
move to the right here, and
it would give us effective
reductions and the required SNR
norm by the coding gain of
the lattice and the shaping
gain of the region.
And we'd get the same curve
moved out over here.
Again, as in the binary case,
typically we're going to get a
larger number of near neighbors,
leading to a larger
coefficient out here.
We want to normalize this
per two dimensions.
Per two dimensions, it's only
4 for the baseline.
But in general, we're going to
get a KS of lambda, the number
of nearest neighbors per two
dimensions, which is going to
raise this a little.
And that will lower
the effective
coding gain down here.
But we've basically, by these
large constellation, high SNR
approximations, we've really
reduced the analysis of
lattice constellations to a
very simple task, just to
analyze what's the coding gain,
what's the shaping gain,
number of nearest neighbors,
plot the performance curve,
end of story.
So we'll start there next time.